three beloved grand theft auto games
have been re-released as part of the
definitive edition the visuals and
controls of gta 3 vice city and san
andreas have been updated and upgraded
and getting three classic games for one
makes this package a pretty sweet deal
sadly these remasters are currently
suffering from glitches audio problems
and a mess of strange visuals so here's
our list of six things that rockstar and
grove street games need to fix if you
like gta or video games in general
remember to subscribe to gamespot for
more let's begin
the original grand theft auto 3 opens
with a police van traveling through a
rainy liberty city before being attacked
it's your first look at the game's open
world and it really sets the mood the
definitive version does the same but oh
my god that rain what is happening what
was once a subtle drizzle over the
screen is now an assault to the eyes
it's not just that it looks worse than
the original but it makes visibility
extremely unclear this issue affects all
three games but it hits gta 3 the
hardest as it rains in liberty city
quite frequently of all the strange
graphical glitches in this collection
this one we would love to see fix the
most
aiming at your targets is sometimes more
trouble than it's worth in gun heavy
battles against multiple enemies
targeting tends to lock onto the wrong
person usually of the unarmed variety
this gta 5 and san andreas hybrid style
of aiming works when there are 3-5
enemies but if you're surrounded which
happens a ton you're at the disadvantage
no matter which gun you have there is a
quote classic style of aiming available
in the game's menu but it's not nearly
as fast or precise at snapping multiple
targets nor does it have the color-coded
health like before surviving gunfights
in the original ps2 version comes easier
as a result
the character models we've all seen them
fortunately the main group of characters
seems to have gotten away unscathed but
everyone else in the definitive version
is looking rough some models like cj's
first girlfriend denise look like
completely different people some are
downright terrifying many lack any
facial details and share the same creepy
eyeballs
[Music]
gta's longer multi-step missions feature
some crucial steps to help get things
done the definitive edition currently
lacks most of these leaving players with
long unskippable moments with no context
when the time comes to begin the mission
new and even returning players will be
met with little to no follow-up
instructions in our play time this issue
occurred in gta san andreas four times
at least we're happy to report that the
breach tab in the menu can finally come
in handy for a quick catch-up but let's
be real this information should not be
missing
at launch gta's definitive edition has
some noticeably harsh audio problems the
most prominent one we found is the
sinking of cutscene dialogue or the lack
of sync
and you'll see how we try out subtle
things without recourse to
unnecessary violence
all right i'll ride with you
other issues include music track
skipping almost as if cj were actually
listening to a cd
also during cut scenes just before
fading to black dialogue can get
abruptly cut
let's go [ __ ]
this new york look like it's up to us
we shall fight to the
this category is a catch-all of all the
little things that seem to have slipped
through the cracks we'd love to hear
yours in the comments but here are some
we've found
transparency effects haven't held up too
well this includes everything from car
fires to ryder's blunt smoke to smoke
grenades barely functioning
what the why isn't t-bone dying he's a
bullet sponge
i rose up to hitman level already with
my pistol why won't you die
other noticeable bugs include tommy
versetti's glitchy crouch animation when
firing a weapon missing or invisible
assets like this bridge shaky license
plate graphics that pop in and out
hairstyles like this high fade not even
working unless we forget about the
constant lag on the nintendo switch
version especially while docked this is
what a building exploding looks like
uncut
there are also some updates to the
lighting and color effect which take
away some of the magic when it comes to
grand theft auto san andreas
specifically the early 90s vibe was
illustrated perfectly in the original
with its sunny deep orange tint this
well established look for the game has
been dramatically shifted in the
definitive edition where the regular
palette of the city's colors resemble
that more of gta v
even with bloom lens flare and fidelity
mode all turned on the 1990s look of san
andreas hasn't fully been restored
without that southern california orange
glaze we come to expect
anybody in the world
it's hard to complain about a trilogy of
games that have brought us years of joy
these aren't terrible or even bad
remasters but if rockstar wants to use
the term definitive we hope these issues
and more can be addressed so that
players can enjoy these games for more
years to come let us know what else you
think should be fixed in the comments
drop a like if you enjoyed the video and
as always thanks for watching
[Music]
you